[Music]
my father was a warrior and they used to
kill many many many Lancia he used to
tell me how dangerous Lancer I used to
headlock
[Music]
when I was a young boy I thought I'll be
growing up until a lance
[Music]
but now relax
because there's no lines in sample
[Music]
[Applause]
we found an armored truck so we think is
in the area now so we're going to look
for her we just got our signature on
just scanning around and now see if
she's still there
northern Kenya is one of the few places
in the world where you can see livestock
wildlife people are living together oh
wow
that there see the laughs but when Lions
are struggling to find food they come
into contact with local communities and
often will target livestock
so generally have said to me if we want
to stop people killing lions we've got
to engage this warrior demographic he
came up with our program which is called
warrior watch for centuries our tribe
depend on their livestock for their
livelihood so as a warrior we provided
security for our livestock and protect
livestock from land we go I'm in the
morning before they left of our list and
see where the lands are we know the
lands are in the area we go back and
spread that awareness within the
community so that they can avoid those
areas the same style we use to kill the
last now we use that knowledge to party
relax my tribe are very good boy wash
program because that will save that list
and also will save the legislation our
goal is to promote coexistence between
people and lions in northern Kenya and
make sure that we respond to everything
that's happening and that the lions are
safe during this very critical time we
have never seen the river dry at this
time of the year there's no enough water
people were like it's a really really
challenging time right now communities
are struggling to take their livestock
into areas to find enough grazing
there's no water for any of the animals
both livestock and Wildlife
the water is underground and and this is
how we get water for what 111 in our
list and also for people it is how we
are survival
[Applause]
[Music]
someone of just colas and say the
community at the function so we're just
going there and take to see if people
are shooting those lines
[Music]
the Warriors will respond as soon as
they ever hear from any of their network
that gunshots have been heard or there's
any conflict the guys respond so quickly
curls have just come to land Heineken
and the lands of very scan the lands of
scared of the cows because of people we
know that we kill cows people tell them
you know we'll what would the new
[Music]
so we found out that when they let's
talk wire drinking water then the
elephant came there so people who are
shooting up on the air to scare away I'm
still be no concern about the world life
in general but luckily it was not lions
because we have soft blue lines Lions
can live with people coexistence is
possible as long as the people are
willing to accept the lion presence and
that's what's happened in the last
couple of years people have accepted
lions tolerated them the Lions feel
areas that they're safe in and they've
just recovered in areas where they never
used to be if you want to make a
difference if you want why life to
succeed involve the people of living
with wildlife because really that's the
key to their success
here are the several communities are the
ones protecting the wildlife and I have
a lot of cope because of that
I'm hoping but my community accepting
lands tell BIA their plans for the
future generations
[Music]
you